هل تفسر قول بوتين الآن إنه
مستعد للتفاوض بشأن نوع من
التسوية مع أوكرانيا بالطبع
إنه يخسر في ساحة المعركة كل ما
يمكنه فعله هو مهاجمة أهداف مدنية
وجعل الأوكرانيين بائسين هذا هو
الشيء الوحيد الذي يتعين عليه القيام به ويتم
دفعه  خارج البلد الذي تم
طرده من أوكرانيا ، لذا فهو الآن
يرغب في التوقف عن التفاوض على وقف إطلاق النار
والتمسك بما حصل عليه ووضع العبء
على أوكرانيا في أوكرانيا.
إن بلدنا الذي تعرفه
مثيرًا للاهتمام لأنه خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ولأول مرة
أطلق عليها بوتين اسم حرب الاقتباس ،
وفي الماضي كان من الممكن أن يتم
القبض عليك في روسيا إذا وصفتها بأنها
حرب كان عليك أن تسميها "يا لها من حرب خاصة".
العملية العسكرية بالضبط ستذهب
إلى السجن إذا وصفتها بأنها حرب
وخرجت من الرئيس بوتين ، قال
إنها حرب يجب أن ننهيها ، إنها
حرب وهي تصل إلى
الشعب الروسي.  لقد
فهموا أنهم يخسرون تلك الحرب في الحرب "ب
" ولهذا السبب يتحدث الآن
عن المفاوضات